uh chairman script
as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to the
department of
safety please note that there's no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with emerging the
emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability
to communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91k anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email lba
underscore fiscal at leg
dot state dot nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
uh when each member states their
presence please also state whether there
is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
so representative lynn would you call
the role please
yes uh thank you madam chair um
representative bucco
and representative danielson are not
present
representative heath mary heath here in
manchester new hampshire
at my home and i am here with my husband
in the other room thank you um i'm bob
lynn
from windham i am uh here in my home i'm
alone in the room my wife is elsewhere
in the house
um representative uh murray
kate murray is here in newcastle dogs up
with me and david is downstairs doing
his thing
thank you representative
yes i'm joe petry my wife is roman
along with a dog in farmington
thank you and representative umberger uh
yes i am still in kearsarge
and uh my husband is in the house
uh looks like he's cutting bread for the
birds which is a good thing
mary maybe we can spread it out in your
backyard there
all right thank you very much um all
right
okay thank you um
welcome commissioner quinn and
um mr lavoy today we
are going to do um
a little bit of a dive into the what's
going on
in in safety and so
i know that you had um
you had sent uh some changes
that you needed to have made and
hopefully
everyone has uh has received those
uh they're on my other computer that has
decided that i'd rather have a black
screen but i'll get that back up
so if we could i would um
like whoever wants to go ahead to please
do so
so i just wanted to say good morning to
everyone and just for the record uh
robert quinn i am alone on the third
floor in my office
and i'm joined by the director of
administration steve avoid
who is in his office on the first floor
and both of us
um have the material you have so i am
going to ask
uh steve to start us off please
thanks commissioner good morning good
morning madam chair members of the
committee um what i'll do is i'll share
my screen for the
errata listing that that was provided
yesterday um late yesterday just to kind
of go over these at a high level so you
understand what we're asking for
um if you have any questions please stop
me along the way
um everyone can see the screen yeah
no problem okay so the first section
here this is to change the revenue
funding
um from agency income 009
to a class 004 which is related to
intra-agency transfers this is just a
new
a relatively new way that das is asking
us to record
grants that we award to ourselves so
typically
when we award a grant to ourselves in
the past we've recorded an agency income
now it's going to stick out and show
that it's an intra-agency transfer
both of these revenue sources are still
other income
when it rolls up so there's no change to
funding it's really just an accounting
adjustment
the next page um num
item number two this is the same
situation except this is dealing with
grants that we receive from external
um state agencies so so agencies that
are not the department of safety
this includes grants we get from the new
hampshire department of justice
the new hampshire department of
transportation so again in the past we
recorded these as
agency income using revenue source zero
zero nine
and the it needs to be recorded as
federal revenue received from another
state agency instead and so we're
requesting that change
no impact it's still other income
the third item here this has to do with
the accounting unit that we use to
support
our new hampshire hospital security
operations
we work with the new hampshire
department of health and human services
in new hampshire hospital to budget
those security operations each year and
our budgets need to align
what happened in this case is that there
were adjustments to our benefit amounts
at das through the budget process which
reduced
um which reduced the our appropriations
and um we need to increase our
appropriations here to match what's
budgeted on the new hampshire hospital
side
the 1.596 and 1.691 and 22 and 23
and so these were amounts that we had
originally reduced our budget by
to meet the agreed-upon amounts but
since there were savings and benefits
we'd like to add these back in and this
will align our amounts with
health and human services at new
hampshire hospital
okay the last two items here oh sorry
yeah on uh on the third one
um
does health and human services pay for
this or do we pay for it
health and human services pays for these
services directly 100
okay thank you yeah
and then the last items are listed as
4-1
oh there might be another question
sorry mary go uh representative go ahead
mir
oh thank you madam chair um what is the
source of those health and human
services revenue
is that gen coming from general fund or
other funds
that i don't know um i just know that
they
they transfer the funds for us and and
we coordinate with them on the amount
required to provide the security
i i don't know what their funding source
is on their side right thank you
[Music]
representative heath uh you can send an
email to jess
edwards and ask him that question
all right thank you okay and uh you know
i'm i'm sure he'll
have an answer or if he doesn't uh he'll
get one for you
right thank you um
okay and then the last item here i'm
listing is 4.1 and 4.2 because they are
related
um again there's there's no impact
overall to our funding sources but there
was a keying error that occurred
when we were adjusting our funds our
fund mix at the
governor's phase which there's a debt
service amount within the
office of the commissioner which needs
to be funded at 100
highway funds and unfortunately right
now it's not so what we're requesting
is that we increase the highway fund
portion for the the amount in the
commissioner's office accounting unit
and decrease the general funds with an
offset for the exact same
um general and highway fund changes in
4010 which is the uh enforcement
accounting unit in state police
so again it's it's neutral no impact on
the state budget
it's really just shifting our fundaments
and aligning it to where we had
intended it to be at the end of the
governor's phase
okay um nikki i guess
is there anybody that has any other
questions
oh i'm sorry representative murray ah
thank you madam chair
um mr lavoy can you just go over again
you know the highway fund is has a
certain amount
does this impact what else you would be
able to do with the highway fund that
these funds are coming out of that
instead of the general fund
does that make sense sure yeah that's a
good question um
there's no impact whatsoever so our our
highway fund draw
in at a for the entire department is
unchanged
all that we've done is shifted where the
highway funds are coming
are being charged to so if you look here
you'll see that
in 4.1 there's an increase of 993
000 and in 4.2 there's a decrease
equal to the same amount 993 so
no impact um whatsoever on the amount
that we're spending for highway funds
it doesn't free up highway funds it just
moves them to a different account
thank you
um is there anybody that has a problem
with any of these changes
okay then could i have a motion to
accept the
changes that um safety has
uh provided to us
okay do i have a second second
all right thank you um representative
lynn would you call the role please
certainly um uh uh representative heath
yes uh
representative lynn i vote yes also uh
representative murray murray votes yes
representative petrie patriot votes yes
representative umberger votes yes
uh madam chair the vote is uh five to uh
nothing uh in favor of the change
well safety got through very easy on
that one
i think thank you very much uh
representative von berger and
um director levoy
absolutely our pleasure we uh we like
those easy ones
um yeah
so um
is there any is there anything else that
you want to bring up this morning before
we
look at our line by line
uh review of your budget um
yes uh madam chair there is one more
piece that i wanted to
um to bring up for consideration
when we met last week we started talking
about house bill 2
and there's a new program that was added
to provide body cameras
and cruiser cameras for locals uh it's a
million dollars
in appropriations um a uh
non-lapsing continuously appropriated
fund and um and at the time i had
mentioned that um we would be seeking a
full-time position
to help administer that fund um we um
we did um we did go back and and look
and and
and made some adjustments to our
original request that we thought would
um
reduce the cost um in doing so so we we
um are changing our request from a
program
specialist position to a business
administrator one position
uh which is a labor grade 21 and that
would be 73 000
in uh fy 2022 and
76 000 in fy 2023
and we would also um be open to making
that a
a full-time temporary position using
that language so it aligns with
the program if the program expires
within the two-year biennium then the
position could expire along with it
but if it goes longer we would be able
to have those discussions moving into
the next biennium to determine
if we needed to continue the position
and so we would request that language be
added to
the hb2 line authorizing safety
to um to fund and hire that full-time
temporary
business administrator one
representative thank you madam chair and
where
in the budget will that position be
reflected because i'm assuming
that you are asking for general funds of
which there are not very many
right and so that would be that would be
up for um
up for the committee to to to decide i
mean one option is there's the million
dollars appropriated for the program
um it might make sense to include it
there
and so then that would essentially
reduce that million dollars by this
amount as far as funding
available to distribute but it would
allow us to distribute those funds
because without this position we're not
sure how we would make that happen
may i follow up madam chair absolutely
so that's a million dollars of general
funds
and that um is
funding that um is very scarce
um i also believe the program is very
important and it was i believe a leak
recommendation but realistically
are we going to be able to afford that
million dollars from your safety budget
which has been so
devastated um by cuts
i mean criminal the the lab i just
going through your budget um was
disturbing to see how much
you have had to cut so that's my
question to you
yeah um that that that that's a good
question
so the the house bill
um appropriations house bill 2
appropriations
are not reflected within our current
operating budget
so those get added in after the fact if
they're approved
and this is an important program and
it's a priority you know all the way up
to the to the governor's level
um to your point funding is scarce
and so um whichever wherever these funds
go if they're supporting cameras or some
other
purpose there's only so many dollars to
go around um
this this is a program that's in that's
in hb2 we do think that it's it's useful
our our purpose here is really to say if
we are to administer it moving forward
we need a resource uh in order to do so
and to do so correctly
thank you representative heath if i if i
could just add to that
you know steve and i have been talking
offline you know quite a bit about this
and i think you know he raises a good
point
i think that we can stand this up and
and have a program and have a process
but again he's going to need the help to
administer it just like you know we've
done in the past with other other
programs but
you know we are we are working very
closely on our own
project for um for digital evidence
our rfp has been pushed out um
a bit due to the complexity of it so you
know that is
probably going to be one of our top
projects moving forward
our own to outfit and equip and manage
the new hampshire state police with
digital evidence which includes
all evidence pictures data
voice not only on the cruiser cameras
and body cameras we will have both
but all of our digital evidence so you
know so this this piece here
which would be for local law enforcement
to apply for these grant dollars needs
to be managed correctly because we want
to make sure we
we i have to ensure that our project is
uh done correctly
which we've got a big team here pretty
much led by
assistant commissioner rick bailey and
colonel noyes
so two separate issues but both very
important
may i just follow up one more time then
based on what
what the commissioner just said yes go
ahead please
commissioner are your funds for your
project
jeopardized because of this item
i i i don't believe so and i think that
they're two separate
we know what we have right now in the
budget but we're waiting to see when the
rfp comes back
you know we there's a lot of you know
uncertainties here but i'll let steve
speak to
you know the funding source the million
and what we have for our own project
steve
yeah no our this is really unrelated
um so we budgeted for our project based
on the information we had
as the commissioner mentioned technology
is
we're we're trying to make sure we get
the best deals we've pushed the rfp out
a little bit
we'll know more about the true cost in
in
the next several weeks um we we hope
that we've budgeted enough we think that
we have
but there's a chance that we still we we
may have under budgeted
um so i i don't believe that these are
in conflict with our
funding because i i feel like what we
have is is where we need to be within
our budget
with the understanding that we'll know
the real number within it within a few
weeks
representative lynn you have a question
yes uh thank you madam chair i'm i'm i'm
just wondering mr
voip um i i if
if you could sort of explain in a little
more detail what it
is exactly that you envision
this person would do with respect to
as i understand it this million dollars
is not
is not for the use of the the state
police or the department of safety
itself but it's for local
uh local and perhaps county police
departments and so
i i i guess what i'm not clear on is
if this is if this is effectively just a
sort of a
pass through of money um
to the to the locals so to speak um
what what you know what are you
what is the person that's going to be
that you're you're
proposing to hire going to exactly be
doing sure
sure yeah no it's a good question so so
this
is this is treated as a grant program to
locals
um so if you think of of of
i don't know the exact number of of
towns and municipalities with the police
force
but let's just say it's it's 200 or
thereabouts
who may be eligible and may want to take
advantage of this program
the first step as the commissioner noted
first step is we need to work with the
ag's office and develop the parameters
of this program
what can you apply for what type of
cameras are are allowed
are we going to require certain um
retention data is there you know what
what components can we buy
cameras will we fund cameras and the
um the computer data backup to secure
the evidence or
only the physical cameras themselves all
those pieces will have to be worked out
then what this position will do is this
position will come in
and administer this like a grant program
what that means is
we'll have some sort of an application
process
that 200 approximately 200
municipalities
would submit applications based on their
um their plans to implement their costs
those would be reviewed in addition uh
in to make sure they're in conformity
with the administrative rules
around the program funds would then be
awarded to the municipalities
in order to be awarded the
municipalities they would need to then
accept the money
at the local level provide evidence of
that acceptance back to us
and we would now then need to go to the
gnc and provide
a grant document agreement to the
council for approval
we're assuming that each one of these
projects will likely exceed the ten
thousand dollar
gnc threshold so now we have 200
governor and council items that need to
be
prepared reviewed processed
appropriately
this is before we've officially started
the project we haven't awarded the funds
yet
so that's to get these things moving
once the
once the grant award has been accepted
and approved by gnc the locals have to
implement their project
now they have to submit for
reimbursement giving us receipts
invoices evidence of payment that needs
to be reviewed
again with admin rules that which will
be established processed
um and then payments would be entered
through the system
and released to the to the locals um and
then at which point would have a
close-out process to make sure if the
grant award was x amount of dollars
you've submitted your final
reimbursements over the next several
months
um if there's a balance left we would
de-obligate that money
to return it to the revolving fund
and be available for others to use so
it's really that
that process times 200
and that's that's why we just don't have
the administrative resources
to ensure that the funding is
distributed equitably and in accordance
with the administrative rules
once those are established
thank you
okay if i remember correctly
the commissioner has six months
to work with the ag to come up with all
of these things is that correct
yes the process yes the process
so do we need to
hire this person
for a full year to begin
or should we uh give the commissioner
and the ag
uh time to set the program up
and then bring the person on
we could give them time to set the
program up and bring the person
on um but i wouldn't want to give
i if if we're planning to launch within
six
months then i think the most amount of
time that we would need would be
several maybe three months
because we want the individual to be up
to speed and knowledgeable
about the program itself the state
processes
what's expected we need to get them
trained so that we can move this money
out as quickly as possible once it's
ready so i'd hesitate to
go a full six months and then hire the
person because i think that'll cause a
delay
in the administration of the program but
we could delay the hiring for
for several months um maybe maybe a nine
month
maybe nine month funding for year one
that might make sense
thank you
i'm i'm making notes over here so that's
why i'm
i'm not i'm not talking so are there any
other questions
that folks have on this particular item
representative murray now thank you very
much um mr lavoy can you just speak
briefly about
uh are there some municipalities that
already have the body cameras um
would this be primarily for smaller
communities that don't have the
resources that say a portsmouth would
have
i have to defer to the commissioner on
that on um
yeah i think back back to what um you
know somebody said it was a leak
recommendation i believe the
recommendation is encourage
you know encourage but i believe it's a
would be an unfunded mandate to require
them to all get the cameras
there are a lot of police departments
that do have them now you know i can
think of a
you know handful off the top of my head
i won't mention them but i think to
steve's point that's why
you know the process is something that
we're really going to have to work on
with the ag you know
what are the parameters who gets the
money who doesn't do we look at what are
their
opportunities within their own budgets
you know how do we
you know is it a partial funding um you
know we would obviously want them
want to get um we want to make sure that
it went
to to meet the needs of those that
needed it the most
so um do we look at well you know do we
gauge one town against the other do we
start so i think that's why
the details of this everything has to be
done fairly so that's what
you know myself and the attorney general
are gonna have to sit down and discuss
ahead of time because
everybody i'm sure who wants to go in
this direction is going to
probably apply for some state funds for
this and i get asked the question all
the time are there federal funds you
know are there other funds
i mean everybody wants us but like like
i said
earlier i'm focused on the state police
right now i have to make sure you know
we've got 260 plus
uniform state troopers we're gonna have
to equip with body cameras
and cameras in the cruisers so it's a
lot of work but
i think it's a great idea honestly to
give you know opportunities out there
because it is
this is where we want to go as a state
thank you
representative heath you have a question
yes thank you
commissioner i think your statement
is very important and i think we have a
priority
and that's the state police we have
minimal dollars and with the newest
funds coming out of washington i believe
that
municipalities will be um
getting quite a bit of funding and
i just i this budget
when i think about the lab and the the
wait time that's going to have to take
place
i think about the motor vehicle
department that
wait times are going to be increased in
good conscience
i just don't know how we possibly
can fund this and yes i agree it's
critical for our towns and
municipalities
and i know that many um communities are
talking about this
but truly with the shape that your
budget
is in right now and chances are we're
going to have to cut more
i can't in good faith vote for this
i am sorry no i respect that
okay are there any other comments
or whatever on this
okay uh seeing none um
we will um slog through
this uh this
uh book yeah this budget
so um is there anyone that has any
questions
that they would like to uh like to ask
the commissioner
or or mr lavoy
they might are scattered about so can i
pop in when
we get to or skip over you know if we
skip something that i have a question
can i pop in at that point
uh actually uh reps and murray if you
if you want to go through your questions
and then uh if any of us have questions
on those
sections or pages we'll uh
we'll jump in happy to
take that
so should i just go ahead then let's go
ahead and just give us the page number
so we can
find it in our book i think you answered
this the first time but i'm not sure
it's page 376
and um where did the ignition interlock
device program go
that moved to um the financial
responsibility accounting unit which is
2315. um
[Music]
it's still within the dmv uh it just
moved within that
that area and i can that is on
page
um 493 steve
yep 493 thanks mickey how'd you get that
so fast wow
i'm working off the electronic the
control f is quicker than flipping the
pages
okay yep so we've so we've absorbed that
within accounting unit 2314.
and the positions that are scattered
throughout here i mean you're missing a
lot of positions
they're all reflected in the budget here
the numbers
they're reflected in the dollars so so
the salary and benefit amounts are lower
the position count they are not
reflected in the position count
so the position count includes all the
unfunded positions in them
right yep
and please if people have questions i'm
going through my notes here but if there
are other questions
um i don't want to take time on flipping
through
notes on page 402
is that a new program the um
that's all a federal grant for one year
uh yes yes so that is to implement a um
it's the seaview program so this is a we
brought this item forward
through fiscal um and it will not be
completed
uh during this biennium and this
implements a single
sign-on system for state police
commercial enforcement
right now when they pull over a a
commercial vehicle they have to query
several different databases
to get the information they're looking
for this will allow them to make one
query in the system and will return all
the safety and
historical information about the carrier
at that one time so
we just accepted that in this fiscal
year through fiscal
but we we believe that uh we'll be able
to complete the work on that grant next
year
um 405 the substance abuse enforcement
it looks like you have a slight increase
very slight increase
but there's the numbers um can you just
sort of explain because it looks
the bottom line is the same but there's
change between the adjusted and the
governor's recommended
apparently you got equipment which you
won't get this year but
um benefits are you hiring people i
guess just a little narrative around the
substance abuse enforcement
yeah sure so this is the accounting unit
where we have our mobile enforcement
teams
um are paid out of so so those staff
and the related equipment to those for
those staff
the equipment numbers themselves have to
do with vehicle replacements
um and so those vary year by year and so
that's why you see some
some variation there and then obviously
salary and benefits
um will vary as well as people are
promoted into
those roles or hired into those roles so
all in all it's it's relatively flat
with
fy um with fy21 budgeted amounts
um and uh
yeah that that that's primarily that's
primarily it one of the key pieces here
too
is that the um the granite shield
component of this
which you can see there's some grants um
some grant pieces that that's not
reflected in here so this is kind of a
companion component to the granite
shield grants to locals
uh the granite shield grants to locals
are not that's not a program that we
fund within our operating budget
and so that's not reflected here thank
you uh
406 can you speak to the agency income
this is new equipment that you're
getting and it looks like it's
is this did this not happen because of
covid or
um nope this is so what you'll see what
you're probably seeing there's several
um
several grants where there's zero
budgeted in 2021.
um we we in the past
if we were not 100 certain that we were
receiving the federal money
we opted to not budget the grant and
come to fiscal
based on comments from the committee um
we've shifted our focus
and we're budgeting estimated uh
receipts for these programs
so as not to have to come to fiscal
throughout the biennium
and so that's the case here normally we
would go to fiscal to accept this money
in and the exact amount
we're now projecting what we expect to
receive in the next several years
and yes this is this is agency income
this is
money from the office of highway safety
that gets awarded to
the division of state police that agency
income 009
line the adjustment that we requested
and that the committee approved this
morning
we'll change that to reflected that
intra-agency and make it more clearer
excuse me represent murray since we're
right
right here i have a question on the
cold case unit
um
i i guess that what my what my question
is is
what is the benefit of
the cold case unit and
how i know that over the years we've
done it with volunteers we've done it
with people
we've done all corn all kinds of
different things
but um what do we uh what are we looking
at
um for that has it accomplished anything
so on yeah i'll take that one steve
so i'll tell you you know and i'm sure
representative lynn would understand
this from his years
as a judge you know there there comes a
time when
um cases um are categorized as cold
a cold case and then there's cases that
are active so when a case is cold or
unsolved
you've still got victims you've got
families you've got evidence you've got
you've got books you've got you've got
hope you've got hope that new
evidence might arise you've got hope
that you know um
an informant may present him or herself
to provide information
you've got a lot of work that can still
be
done and it takes uh it takes
investigators
there have been some um you know
volunteers that have gone in and looked
at books and
and analyzed uh reports uh but you've
got
um you've got prosecute prosecutorial um
uh staff at the attorney general's
office so it's a team
i think it's very important to continue
to work these cases
we have uh had some success um
it's it it's a lot of work though and
each case is different
but i think it's it's important to
continue to
to have that to to have that um that
team there
um not only it's it's in the interest of
justice
you know to continue to look and work at
these and every day we
you know we get letters we get new
information arrests are made
and so um i think you know to answer
your question representative romberger i
think it's important to the uh
to the victims the victim's family um to
continue to seek
justice and find out who committed the
most
you know egregious crimes in the state
and we've got a good team working on it
it just continues to
be something that they go in every day
they're working
representative heath you have a question
thank you madam to you that was one of
my questions
as well um because we see a a
an increase in that level of funding so
i guess i have a few questions
um in terms of um is this a match
for federal dollars and would it be
possible
to just um
because of this the nature of this
budget this year what would
be the impact if these funds were to be
reduced
well in what why
which just overall the funding for
salary and benefits class
general fund line yeah well i mean it
would impact the amount of hours that
could be put forward it could impact
uh could be result in you know loss of
investigators so
um yeah i i mean i i think this is an
area that
you know we wouldn't want to look to
reduce because
they're you know it's it's minimally
staffed at this point
and again you've got the major crime
unit that is working you know full-time
on the most
active in recent cases so i
i listen in the interest of the state i
i would uh
not recommend reducing these funds
because we've had all we can do to keep
this this level of staffing
steve yeah no i
i think um i think it's a valid point i
think with the stat with the funding
levels that we have here
there's two full-time positions
dedicated to this
to this service um we reduce anything
and
essentially there's there's really going
to be a significant decline in any cold
case work
um so that that's that's it's
if there were 50 individuals in this
unit we could talk about maybe scaling
back but it's too i think it's too small
to touch
madam chair if i may yes please
are there um a lot of people with whom
you contract with
in this area contract well
these are no they i mean these are
active investigations you need
full-time sworn law enforcement i mean
they can get on a plane and travel
you know out of state to interview
somebody incarcerated in another state
that's
wants to confess to crimes or has
information but
no they're full-time uh full-time
employees
and there's always a attorney general um
who is uh embedded um with the cold case
unit
and obviously you know they they are not
going out and making arrests they're
working hand in hand with the attorney
generals on this
just like any other homicide
investigation and and i will say they
have done
they have had some some great success
and
um it just you can never stop
persevering in these
and again the families uh of these
victims
are continuously asking what is being
done
and providing information so it's a lot
of work thank you for the question
thank you representative murray you had
a follow-up
yes thank you when you say they're
full-time are they full-time on the cold
case unit or are they full-time with
your staff and they do other
they perform other functions as well
full-time cold case
thank you
okay uh represent murray if you want to
go ahead
i was going to skip over to 4 30 to
circle back around the urine and codis
testing lab
are there questions before that uh yes i
did
i did have a question um
this is on page 408
dealing with the um
well first of all i didn't understand
the nhsp join the new hampshire
clique
so that is um that is a highway
office of highway safety funded program
that funds additional um
additional um it's really encouraging
individuals to
use their seat belt so because we don't
have a seat belt law
that's funding to support promoting the
use of seat belts
especially and also enforcing child
safety restraint laws
uh in the state so that's that's an
annual grant
that state police receives from the
office of highway safety
thank you and um your division of state
police permits and licensing
what does the state police do that the
um dmv doesn't do
in what regards representative umberger
the permits in licensing
commonly um referred at times to the gun
line licenses
you know we do the backgrounds and the
permits for out-of-state pistol permits
new um sales for handguns
security guard licenses those types of
um
apartments so really it's completely
different from any dmv functions
okay so all right that those are the
people i visited
you you did visit them
okay so this is um
primarily for uh gun licenses
is that what i'm hearing
yeah primarily gun licenses there's also
um
licenses for private investigators and
security guards and those operations are
handled through here
um and then um also the
the gun line so when uh when an
individual is trying to
uh wants to purchase uh a firearm
um the the federally licensed
reseller has to call the gun line for
the criminal check that's
that gets processed through here this
accounting unit
this is where we have three new
positions to help support that function
to ensure that we can meet the demand
for those services and reduce wait times
so were those new positions or shuffled
positions
those were new positions we had roughly
representative humber
i want to say 65
to 68 don't hold me to this percent
increase in the sales so
we've been extremely busy in there
working with the courts not only on the
purchases but return of the firearms
so we've looked at our internal
processes and essentially we there was
absolutely no way we
could keep up with the statutory
requirements on um
sales on three business days return of
the firearms
and that's why we had the attorney
general i i give
i give him credit for outlining a
process because there's nothing in
statute that says what the extent of a
background check is
it just says we may be the point of
contact so
we were doing a lot more than
we really you know could and we had to
balance
the right of someone to purchase and
have their firearm returned
with the need to do a a safe background
check so we have
something codified now which is a good
roadmap but even with that
when we looked at the numbers we said we
absolutely needed these positions to
keep up with what we're required to do
by law
i
so the what is that state law
or federal law well well it's
it's there's it's state law and there
are federal laws that we have to
adhere to on the background but there's
you know there's requirements for 14
days on
you know we have to turn these permits
around we have to give these approvals
like the ffls within three business days
if we don't
approve it or deny it if it stays
delayed
the purchase can go through so we just
were not
you know we weren't meeting the
requirements
those and that's based by by the
business purchases the federal but we
we follow that
representative lynn you have a question
yes thank you uh madam chair am i
correct commissioner i
i i my understanding is that there's
been
um some complaints um
from uh gun purchasers or maybe firearms
dealers
about the delays that you refer to and
there's
apparently there's even been some
suggestion i don't know if it actually
made it to legislation
uh proposal uh that uh as i understand
the way the system works now if it's a
handgun purchase
the the background check is done by the
state if it's a
long gun purchase it's done by the fbi
and that there was some suggestion that
the state ought to get out of that
business and let the fbi do everything
um uh which in my to my way of thinking
is a
very bad idea but apparently there is
there is at least some
some suggestion uh
to that effect is that is that am i
correct in that
you're you're accurate on both so the
first um
complaints yes we have been um dealing
with
many many complaints uh for our
backlogs and delays and so we've been
addressing that
with the um with the business businesses
so we've looked at our internal process
as i said we've
shifted people we've added people we put
temporary employees in there to keep up
with this
you know this increase in sales and
volume
in and with the courts addressing we
have to do the check
which goes back to the court so that
they can return the firearm back to the
person that it was taken from
but along the lines of discussion yes it
has been discussion on
sending this all to the fbi because the
statute 159 says we may
become the point of contact this goes
back to
when brady initiated that the state was
the point of contact for just the
handgun so
what i have said um in my conversations
is i believe
we are going to do the best we can to
maintain it and keep it because i think
our
check gives a couple more layers of
safety than the fbi check
and that is we query against a list that
comes from the court
of folks that aren't in ncic that have
um
that have restraining orders domestic
orders because they don't have all the
information
and we also do a more thorough check of
the new hampshire state record
because any conviction that isn't
supported by fingerprints
might not be um queried or
are caught in the next check so um we're
going to do the best we can with it i
think our check is
is uh offers uh more safety
and um but again you're correct um and i
don't know where that
is i know there's been discussion but um
as of now we
we have it and we're gonna continue to
just do the best we can with it
right follow up if i may yes please
and no i i appreciate your your response
commissioner
as i understand i i think uh based upon
my discussions with uh
with uh the governor's council that the
governor strongly supports having the
state retain
this check and for the reason for the
reasons that you stated and
as well as just the idea that to my mind
placing more responsibility in
washington as opposed to leaving it
local is just
generally a bad idea um so i i
strongly support what what you propose
yeah and i think what i hear the biggest
you know this there's the check
itself but i think what um what the
what the citizens want is the ability to
talk to somebody if they have a problem
they are denied you know what
what what is the problem so it's that
customer service it's the ability to
pick up the phone and say why am i in a
delayed status and maybe you know
resolve it so
that's exactly exactly no you're exactly
right i think
thank you uh representative murray you
have a question
thank you madam chair um just for
information do you happen to know how
many granite staters
own guns and what's the average number
of guns that a granite stater owns
i don't have that number
i can give you and i will provide
through steve
the number of um transactions that we've
done
that shows the increase but i can't
speak that would be impossible because
you don't know there's no registry on
that and you don't know
what's we don't keep that data so i
wouldn't even begin to
try and answer that i don't think i
could and i don't think the data exists
thank you representative heath you have
a question
i do thank you madam chair um with
regard to
background checks that's a pretty
complex
area because every single one of our
school districts
um teacher uh preparation programs
there are huge demands on that
department
because um people can't hire
a new teacher without a background round
check
we can't have send our student teachers
into schools without a background check
so how
is your office handling
the demand and um
what suffers when you have to reduce
um staff in that area sure well
so so this comes up a lot background
check
what does that mean that that means
different things to different people
so we do a background investigation for
uh
a new trooper so the background
investigation could include
going out and interviewing you know
former employees and looking at school
records and looking at credit checks and
speaking to neighbors and you know not
just verifying information but
going out and proactively looking at
somebody's background
what you are speaking to what we look at
with the um
with the with the transactions is a
check of um
the next check so we do the ncic check
anything fingerprint fingerprint based
supported
and we look at the state criminal
history now i will share this with you
there could be a conviction in
say the state of ohio where they didn't
fingerprint
it wouldn't show up on the fbi check and
unless you check
all 50 individual states so what we have
done is we look at
the state that they are born the state
that they reside in
we're looking at the state of new
hampshire and we do the next check
and we think that that is uh
comprehensive it's reasonable
and um you know but again
the fbi check what is going to come up
on that is going to be based on
fingerprints
so if somebody was arrested and
convicted but the fingerprints were not
taken
that would not show up unless you
queried individually on
state to state thank you so we handle it
it's automated and um so we have like a
federated check now when you put the
name and date of birth in so that it
rolls through them
and uh if i may inquire a little bit
more
madam care certainly um
with regard to the background checks
for weapons um it seems that there's an
increasing
number of weapons across our state um
how deep and how how
just based on what you just said to me
how do we know
that in an individual maybe who moved to
new hampshire from another state
um is really a person who should be able
to be licensed to carry a weapon
well there's no requirement for a
a license so a background check rather
yeah so i guess it's two sep separate so
the state does not require that but if
they were going to purchase they would
go through the same
check that i just spoke of would check
the knicks would check the state
so we would do the standard um
we'd do the standard federal check so if
you were to walk into
and purchase a long gun you know a rifle
that would go to the fbi so we have
talked to the head of the sieges of
the fbi and i'm sorry just click my
mouse and we are doing
we're doing i would say i would say
we're doing two
additional layers that they would do
but you know so i does that answer your
question
my because my concern was that is
somebody coming to our state
um and because there isn't well i guess
the the federal
background check would cover every state
and that would be reported back to you
just i was concerned that some things
aren't showing up
on the background check because of the
nature of
um a database
based on somebody's background yeah and
a lot of times what causes these delays
um you know and representative lin can
appreciate this
is our team sees a conviction
in it's it's not clear in the record
whether that conviction is a
disqualifier
for example it could be a dwi
within the last 12 months is it alcohol
related or is it drug related if it's
drugs it could be a potential
disqualifier they have to stop
delay further investigate they see a
simple assault
is it dv related just by looking at the
record they're unsure they stop
delay they have to make a call pull the
rope pull the file out
so what we are looking at now um in in
you know our continuing talks with j1 is
ensuring that
when the circuit courts have a
conviction if it is a disqualifier it's
duly noted
so that it when it goes from the circuit
court to our
criminal records unit and it's uploaded
at night it can get
uploaded correctly to the nix index so
it's all about making sure that what is
a disqualifier is is
is um categorized
as noted but um thank you
are there any further questions on this
okay uh seeing none um
representative murray what's your next
page
um i was going to 431 and a little bit
and just if we can
talk a little bit more about what
they're going to need in the lab
that seems to be such a critical
shortage so we've got the
um you know there's a a cut here
they spoke that they needed additional
people around the lab so i think
that's kind of scattered throughout i
wondered if we could just go back to
their prioritized needs around that okay
before yep before we do that
um i want to ask about um
operation safe commute
that is um
oh i s okay is
okay that's that's agency income
that's that's another highway safety
grant um
okay that's all i need thank you yep
now we'll move to page 431.
so 431 is one of three accounting units
that supports the lab so this is the
urine and codis
area so it's focusing on the dna
database
processing and then also testing
urine for samples of alcohol and
controlled drugs
in this specific accounting unit um
there is one
of the of the unfunded positions in the
lab there's one unfunded position here
and these are in our top priorities to
have filled
because obviously this this falls under
the lab is really if you kind of think
of our
of our lab we have our forensics lab and
we have our toxicology lab
um and so the toxicology lab includes
this area this is a component thereof
um and so that's the lab that deals with
drugs
um and and and testing drugs and those
types of
of activities and that's clearly that
that's an area that's that's important
that we
maintain the the volume of of
testing requests that we're receiving
because backlogs there can have problems
especially if we
move into um move into the court system
there
so there's one of those unfunded
positions here um
it's critical that we that we we get
that funded if there's funding available
to maintain the uh services in in this
toxicology area
the other sections are later in the
budget book and that's where the rest of
the lab positions are
um but they're all they're all critical
yeah it's it's difficult um
i guess you know i just want to make
sure we keep um
those positions in our minds in terms of
how important it is to the work you do
um can you speak to uh fourth
uh page 435 that declare disaster
federal funds sorry uh i believe
representative heath had a question
on uh the urine and codis
apology so
here i just um my question is
um what would be the lag time
based on the cuts um
in the lab
it's i mean if you look at the positions
i mean i think there was six
criminalists and three administrative
two intake and one i think an
administrative assistant
it's hard to really quantify based on
what's coming in but
clearly there would cause delays in
those
in those areas i mean we wouldn't be
budgeting we wouldn't
for these positions so the exact time
a week or it it's based on how much
what's coming in you know so
um it's hard to give an exact day but we
can say that it would cause delays
a follow-up madam chair certainly
so we've seen a reduction um
in the number of overdose deaths
uh from the pandemic well
the pandemic has reduced the the
utilization
of of drugs it appears but
i don't know how long that's going to
last
and i hear concerns that that come
from our local police departments um
about the the amount of time for
processing
when it comes to certain things and i
think the county has some of those
issues as well so are we just going to
exacerbate that problem
further um as as we come out of the
pandemic and
and we're seeing an increase again in
those areas
which i'd love to say we won't see it
increase but i i fear that we will
yeah so i'll i'll take that i mean
clearly we want to fund these positions
i mean that's that's our priority uh as
steve said
you know we we are going to see a
reduction in the deaths this year i
believe
um i can't give the exact number but um
but
by no way shape or form should we you
know
be raising a victory flag at this point
i mean we're dealing with
you know significant increases in
methamphetamine our narcan
administrations are up so we are seeing
the reductions in deaths but
um again we are we are not uh
in a position where we want to take our
our our foot off the gas here
we've got we've got a lot of work to
continue to do here and
um you know i think this is uh a
relatively
you know minor adjustments in the lab
but if we can get those positions
uh melissa staples and her crew will
meet the needs of the local
law enforcement they also help the
federal agencies as you know
but again the critical areas for them is
making sure there's
lab you know analysis are done for grand
jury and they need them for court and
there's deadlines
and they have a they know how to
prioritize uh
and and they will meet those those those
demands you know what really gets them
representative heath is when they have a
homicide
investigation and they can have you know
200 plus
pieces of evidence exhibits i mean
that's when it gets complicated and
complex
crime scenes that have you know multiple
uh multiple crime scenes with you know
various degrees of evidence that has to
be recovered but
but again we the lab is in good shape if
we can
get these positions where they need to
be and we're expanding to increase our
capacity with uh with digital evidence
as we've talked about before but we have
a good we have a great lab director
melissa took over for tim pifer and
we know the vision and the direction we
want to be going in
representative murray if you would like
to continue
thank you um so on 435
is that coveted related money over the
next two years or what is it
declared disaster federal funds um it's
a mixture
so um this is a mixture of cobit related
and
any presidentially declared disasters so
when we
have major flooding major snow events
that in a presidentially declared
disaster occurs this is where that
funding goes
the the again this is an area where our
past
practice has been to not budget these
accounts
and bring those to fiscal because for a
while the disasters were few and far
between
right now we have i believe it's five
open disasters that we're still
processing
reimbursements on including the covet
disaster which is still ongoing
and so um we do expect funding here
this is this is again it's the the
estimation is the challenging part
because we don't know when coveted will
end and we also don't know if
next week there is a there's a weather
disaster um that would
bring new funding into the state um but
this gives us a starting point
and um and and it's just a slightly
different approach that we're taking to
budgeting these accounts
this go around around some of the
disasters and i'm thinking culvert is
probably a more appropriate
um potentially example of this
does this fund does these monies ease
the strain on you
in other areas
um you know i mean it's just
no uh i i don't think they do so
the the these funds are exclusively
for um response immediate response
to the disaster and then maybe some
um some um additional
additional costs associated with
rebuilding um
those in the infrastructure that was
damaged as a result of this
of the disaster so so they don't support
um the department of safety in any way
we're really the administrator of these
funds and we work closely with the
locals and the municipalities
and other state agencies also who would
be eligible
to make sure that um they're getting um
the most federal support that they
that they can that's eligible under the
law so that money goes to like
for repairing a bridge possibly yeah
repairing a bridge a culvert that washed
out
hazard hazard mitigation representative
steve
talked about trying to advocate for one
position
on the camera program you can only
imagine the amount of administrative
work that's ongoing
in hsem not only for these five but
you know it will be years of uh
administrative work in
billing and paying and processing all
the requests
you know um colbert
representative petry you have a question
yeah thank you madam chair uh
i got a question about block grant
versus
uh having to meet all these requirements
have you ever figured what the cost is
of trying to meet those requirements to
get the money
from the federal government or other
sources
so um i'm i i'm not sure i think
we don't we don't administer any block
grants in particular i do know that
those do have
certain restrictions um these funds in
particular for the disasters are
relatively broad
so it starts with um it starts with an
estimate of what the costs were
the damage done within a county by
county and if it exceeds a certain
uh threshold set by the federal
government then
then the governor can request that the
president declare a disaster and make
these funds available to us
and then they just have to meet certain
requirements as far as was it the
disaster that caused this
this issue with the infrastructure so
it's treated a little bit differently
than my understanding of the block
grants but but then again we don't
administer block brands so my
understanding is limited there
well what i what i meant to say if i
could follow up
is that uh how much of those strings
cost
if they eat maybe block grant wasn't the
best uh
best uh way to express it or the strings
that the federal government puts on
because there is a
there is a cost it's probably a very
significant cost to try to meet
all the matrix of the requirements
so um the first you know each project
has a 25 match so there is a real cost
to start
um and then it's that administrative
burden
um similar to what i was speaking about
with the with the camera project
it's the time spent administratively
reviewing the applications
reviewing the projects comparing those
for allowability for
um that particular event um processing
the paperwork
entering into the contracts um
submitting the
the the payments through the system we
we don't have a
um i don't have a an
estimate of of what that cost is because
it does vary by
disaster but to your point there is an
administrative burden
um fema has continued to push that
burden down onto the states
and so the um division of homeland
security
is really the one that bears the brunt
of that
we there are management costs that are
available to
uh to us to utilize to hire positions to
help us process those
so those go above and beyond the
disaster we can offer
we can hire some individuals we can use
those costs to to buy
computers and equipment and and we try
to maximize that as best as we can
but yes there is there's still going to
be some cost to
to the state and to the locals for for
processing those funds and making sure
that we
remain in compliance um you know an
example might be
davis bacon law which requires that
certain contractors uh there's a minimum
pay amount
for certain projects um that might come
into play depending on the cost of the
project that they're working on
so there there's a there's an example of
some of that compliance
piece that that we would need to
consider and the locals would need to
consider
what's the risk and what's the benefit
of requesting these funds
because all of this is voluntary the
funds are available
people can apply for them or they can
choose not to if they determine the
compliance requirements are too
stringent
thank you okay
uh representative heath i'm sorry thank
you madam chair
just in in response to that isn't it
true though that with the federal
dollars that come into the state of new
hampshire
that normally it's the usual and
customary practice
that administration fees can be
included usually they have some kind of
a percentage
um that you're allowed is that true it
varies
by program to program but yes often
there is a there's an administrative cap
it's usually a percentage
5 10 whatever whatever that might be
program by program
the reality is that um that
administrative cap is not
typically sufficient uh to to to to
fully administer the program
and so that's where additional costs
come in um
but to what extent that that's going to
vary also
if i may madam chair absolutely
it is from just going through your
budget as many times as i have
it would appear to me that
you have had to zero out so many lines
in the general fund
and the um
the note that we see continuously is
federal funds
to what extent would your department
your your agency would be devastated
if you were to deny the use of federal
funds
to your department that's
that's a big question um
it's it's
that's a that that's a big question
certain areas
would absolutely be devastated um
uh homeland security and emergency
management
that division um our our operating costs
are funded by federal funds in there
that would we we would not be able to
function
homeland security would not exist
without those funds that that's probably
the biggest
biggest impact the second largest
impact would be um related to
traffic safety and and traffic
enforcement and highway enforcement and
those types of activities
we have the office of highway safety
receives just under four million dollars
every year
from nitsa and that's for traffic safety
specific activities that's money that
goes to locals
to increase traffic enforcement in the
towns that's money that goes to state
police to increase
traffic enforcement on on the
interstates
um that goes to support promotional
activities to
to encourage people to wear their seat
belt uh even though it's not required
so there would there would be an impact
on highway safety if those funds weren't
available to us
it's it's all of the fema money that
comes and supports the locals hazard
mitigation so after a disaster
there's additional money that becomes
released for locals to apply for
um for projects to prevent future
disasters because if you prevent it from
happening
it saves you money um in in in in the
future because you're not worrying about
repairing things
you're strengthening your infrastructure
that funding would go away
so there are it's intertwined within our
department but not operationally
the operational pieces is homeland
security
all the other divisions would continue
to function operationally
it's just that the scale and level of um
activities would decline because a lot
of those are federally funded
thank you here
excuse me just a second mary if you look
at uh
page 523 it shows that uh
we're getting uh 30 million in federal
funds
so we would we would
have to make that up
uh and uh you know that's
if we think we got problems now add
another
add another 30 million to uh to that
thank you chair i really agree and um as
as a person who worked extensively with
federal dollars in education
it was my experience that the federal
dollars
allowed um you could have but those
funds
and and and what i've seen that you've
done
in your budget so effectively is
combining
local of the general funds along with
the federal funds
to be make and i have to say to your
um to compliment you on the effective
use
of really employing every single dollar
um from the highway fund revolving fund
and
it's it's quite extraordinary to see
what you have managed to do
with the amount of general funds that
that are in this budget
so just a comment thank you
representative petry you have a question
well it's more of a more more of a
comment uh
if we left those funds in new hampshire
instead of taxing uh the
you know our businesses and whatever and
send it to washington and
paying for all that bureaucracy i would
leave it to steve and commissioner quinn
to make better decisions and easier
decisions
thank you thank you interest interesting
comment
okay can i could i add one
one point um this is a follow-up from
representative heath
you had asked a question in our last
meeting um
and and you kind of caught me off guard
and you were asking about moe's
maintenance of effort and um and i and i
stated no we don't have any of those
um that's not accurate um
i it's i so i want to clarify that i
for whatever reason i was focused on
fema and i was thinking fema fema fema
as you can imagine with covet and all
the money that's where my head has been
but um thinking now talking about
office of highway safety office of
highway safety there is an moe
um we have mix app grants that support
commercial enforcement
we have an moe there um and the other
one i can think of
is uh the recreational boater safety
grant from the coast guard
for marine patrol there's one there as
well what my statement afterwards still
stands
we're not in any jeopardy based on the
positions and
that aren't funded here of not meeting
those but i wanted to clarify that as i
as i thought about it just now and i
apologize for that confusion oh thank
you that was a big concern of mine
so representative murray
all right um this is a simple question i
hope i'm on 4th
38th what is rim c rim c
is the radiological instrument
maintenance
and and collabora uh collaboration um
uh calibration
i'm sorry radiological instrument
maintenance and calibration unit
and so they literally um calibrate
radiation detecting devices that are
used to
um provide the monitoring services in
and around the seabrook area
thank you
i've got a ways to move on if there are
other things that are
no you're doing fine keep going um i
think on page 443 we already talked
about the hazard mitigation program
you mentioned you included the fema
there
yep and and the one piece there is um
you know
again kind of talking about requirements
hazard mitigation funds
those are those become available after a
disaster
and the local needs to have a plan in
place that's approved before they can
apply
so it's not money that can just be just
be spent without without a clear plan in
place
i'm going to 471 unless someone has
something before 471 i think this is
an accounting issue but anything before
then
i don't have anything oh married uh
representative i do
on page 427
um in terms of general fund um
amounts for the detective bureau i see
that there's a big
increase in that and my second question
is and i can't find the exact page
but there's um a rather large
retirement amount and
it was zeroed out of the general funds
my big question is where and how are you
going to
replace those funds because that is
certainly
an issue um so thank you sure
um so the first question about the
detective bureau um
that um the the general fund
component um increased there's there's
two components to this account one is
general funds
and one is an agency income source that
agency income source is from
rsa 263 52 it's the driver training fund
and that allows that that gives the
commissioner the authority to
um fund anything within safety up to 1.5
million dollars
and and that has been a source that
we've utilized in this accounting unit
for
for years the the the that means that
the general fund needs to bear
any increases because that's a cap and
so the costs the additional costs
associated with salary and benefits
um and the general you know they're not
significant but there are some increases
here
they're all general fund impacts um
the the retiree health question um
that's also
a very good question uh retiree health
was one of the areas that we
looked at um because the budget was so
tight
um and that was one that we revisited to
make sure that
any dedicated funds that we had were
paying their fair share
of those costs and so we we
redistributed that
funding across the entire budget
based on the individuals who are
receiving retirement health benefits and
where they worked
when they were here and so that's what
we've done is we've reduced the draw
on the general and the highway fund and
um
and spread that out to um to the re to
the dedicated funds that we have
throughout
madam chair may i have a follow-up
please absolutely
um thank you um i guess a couple of
questions
um you've done a lot of work on this
budget to manage all that
um i just want uh some clarification on
what's included
in the revolving fund and then the
highway fund
has taken a huge hit and
um you know every time you have to go to
the highway fund it
it um there's a lot of agencies that
depend on highway fund
and and how is that impacted throughout
your budget
sure um so so the dedicated funds
that that i'm speaking about um
you know i i'll try to list off as many
as i can think of but
there are several but the biggest ones
the most the largest
the fire fund um which supports the fire
marshal's office and the fire academy
um watercraft safety fund that's paid
for with
if it's voter registration fees and that
supports marine patrol
the criminal records fund which is
criminal record fees which supports our
criminal records operations
not permits and licensing that's a
separate piece but criminal records
itself and updating the criminal history
information database
um the 911 fund um which supports
emergency services and communications
um and then there there are some smaller
funds
scattered throughout but those are
really the big the big four
that we have that weren't essentially
weren't
fully paying in to the employees who
used to work for them that are now
receiving retiree health
so you'll see we we have increased
retiree health costs and those
funds we did the analysis to make sure
the fund could sustain it
and it wasn't going to cause any any
long-term concerns
if there were going to be long-term
concerns then this process wouldn't work
for us but
thankfully they were able to absorb it
without without harm to the fun
the second question related to highway
funds
so we we have always taken the approach
at safety at least since i've been here
um and i believe this was the case prior
that
when it comes to funding we're agnostic
we
um we understand and reflect the
importance of uh
we understand and the the importance of
all the different dedicated funding
sources
and the restrictions that are placed
upon them but our
our focus is always going to be to fund
our operations
with whatever funds are available to us
and so
decreases to the highway fund only
impact us
if there's no corresponding general
funds available to fill that gap
um in the past uh under normal
circumstances there's typically some
general funds that
have been used to help prop up the
highway fund
or provide us with the additional
services we need to maintain
the same levels of service the
additional funding we need to maintain
the same levels of service
this budget we we we didn't have that
and so
so this this has been a challenge
um as you can see we've done everything
that we can to
reduce our draw but
it still resulted in us having to unfund
50 positions
and and that's obviously a last resort
for us because as
as i've said before and as a
commissioner said we're we're a
people-driven organization we're service
based
every single division um it's the people
that
execute on our mission and and we need
all of those resources we need more
resources than we currently have if you
know we're being honest but
the money's not there so we make do with
what we have as best as we can
so it's been a challenge
but again if if the highway fund
were to disappear and 35 million in
general funds were to suddenly appear
as long as we fund safety that that's
that's the key focus
you know you know representative berger
i mean steve i
i don't want to not emphasize how
important he's been but we're
not only looking at this budget but
we've got positions like we're able to
fund in this biennium
through grants and i can name a couple
prosecutor positions that are funded by
highway safety
but i know after this biennium we're
going to have to look to
get those funded in our budget because
it's so we're looking
not only at this budget but we're
looking you know three years down the
road
and you know keeping our eye on other
positions that are just you know they're
critical but
you know like the fire fund you know
steve's done when we started this
exercise
he was i would say is innovative he's
had to really look
you know at dispersing these funds
whether it's the it costs retirement
benefits but
looking across this large agency in
seven divisions and how to spread it out
so that everyone was successful and
again as steve said
as long as we're funded that's and we
can go out and do the
do the job that everybody you know um
depends on us to do that's that's all
we're concerned with
madam chair may one more comment please
certainly
you realize that we have to work with
the numbers that we have been provided
and because of what ways and means um
has approved for us to use
unless something significant happens
between now um and when we have to
finalize this budget on march
26th our recommendations um
there are going to be some disastrous
things that we're going to have to do
and i just hope that once this budget
gets to the senate
you can recoup some of those laws and i
apologize
up front because you are so devastated
that it it
just it's um it really bothers me
that actually we're making cuts in the
business taxes
and i see the hits that you are taking
um it just for me it's unconscionable
thank you madam chair for that
opportunity
no problem so uh representative murray
you have
uh some other questions
sure enough um i think he already
answered it i was
asking about the retirees health
insurance it's on page 471 and you
already explained that you
divvied that up across the different um
divisions is that right correct
um in fact the the actual amounts are on
the last page of our
original presentation if you wanted to
see where those ended up
um it shows where where all those
different costs
uh landed from an accounting unit
perspective
all right you've spoken about the grants
management already
i don't know if there's anything you
wanted to add about that um
um just that that's an area that um
well it's within my division so it's
near and dear to me but
that's an area that um we've been
focusing a lot of time to make sure that
we're structured correctly in the
division of administration
to maximize the use of our existing
resources because
if you look at the 30 million dollars in
federal
funds that come through we've got four
full-timers
responsible for compliance with all of
those different programs and there's
more there's more people in the program
specific level so highway safety has
their own program people but
we're looking at a department-wide
standardized
compliance program to make sure that
there aren't any issues moving forward
we certainly don't want to have to give
any of that money back because something
was missed along the way
so just it is a critical area that i
think sometimes gets gets overlooked
that's all and
representative umber giving credit to
steve if you've heard about the amount
of money that we push out in the grant
programs
the process whether it's highway safety
or the you know the the the empg
whatever grant there is steve's looking
at the process to ensure we have
you know as efficient and um um
and paperless as possible so the whole
approval you know updating um
processing invoicing and steve's he's
looking at our whole business model
to ensure that uh it's done as
seamlessly as possible which reduces the
amount of
you know administrative staff that are
needed
by the way safety is not the only one
that has
re-looked at all of their processes over
the last
uh year and uh you know
i i think i mentioned to someone the
other day
that if there's any one good thing that
came out
of the covet epidemic is that it has
caused us all
to rethink how we how we operate
and um and i you know it's
it's great as to how the various
departments have
uh have stepped up and made changes and
so that's just my comment thank you very
much representative heath
madam chair i agree with you
wholeheartedly and um
steve to your credit you have done a
remarkable job with working with all
these funds
now my follow-up question to that is um
i know that
there you regularly are audited by the
federal government um how is your uh
compliance
have you had a number of compliance
issues or are your audits usually clean
no we're usually clean um you know we
get audited as part of the state
single audit um and obviously the
the disaster funds will get audited next
time around because
the it'll be a major program with the
money that's going out
um but but yeah we're we're typically
clean
um you know i think the one outstanding
comment that we have has to do with
um sub-recipient monitoring and
and that there might not have been a um
a risk assessment that was
formally documented before the award
went out
um small from a risk perspective as far
as i'm concerned something we can fix
by reinforcing our existing procedures
but we don't see unquestioned uh we
don't see a question costs
we don't see anything like that as on a
regular basis
thank you okay uh
representative murray where where to
next um i
moved over to page 489 for just over an
overview question
of and i think mr lavoy this is your
area here
um it's a five million dollar hit and
just as you know sort of a
larger overview how is that impacting
the division of
administration
um it's yeah it's significant
and and we it's it's
impacting us by causing delays
uh in service um we we're able to
continue to offer the same quantities of
service we haven't scaled anything back
um but there are going to be increased
delays in how we can support the loca
the locals our our customers um the
other divisions
the the areas that are hit the hardest
are
the asset and resource management bureau
which is where
our our warehouse our inventory
our supply distribution our mail
operations mail room operations we have
some
key positions that are unfunded in there
but we we're trying to change our
processes and
um and and make the changes we need to
to make it work
so um the the big
piece in this area that's missing is the
the deputy director of administration
position
um out of all we have seven divisions in
the department of safety
every division except for administration
has a number two
um and and in administration we really
have
a two-faced mission if you will we we
have to provide services to the
divisions and interact with them and
make sure they're getting what they need
to be done
but we also have to work on process
improvements internally
for our own business and that's the
piece where
i i can't do both um effectively
um and and continue to move us forward
so
it's going to it's going to decrease our
ability to respond
timely to division requests but
we will still be able to deliver all the
resources
and we'll just have to prioritize things
more really kind of work
triaging on a day-to-day basis not the
situation we want to be in long term
but we're going to do what we need to do
to support the mission
it's just not a sustainable model it's
going to cause a lot of additional
turnover
staff are already stressed and and
they're having
trouble um you know i i'm the the best
part about our staff
is i have to tell talk to our employees
and say listen
i'm the director i'm telling you it's
okay that you're not going to get to
this
because our our our employees feel awful
they really feel awful that they can't
they can't get this package delivered
today because they just they're out of
time
there's no one else to do it there's no
overtime it's gonna have to wait till
tomorrow
and i'm telling them it's okay it's okay
i understand just keep communicating
with me so i know and we'll we'll work
through it as best as we can
i was thank you for mentioning that i
was going to ask about the human toll
all around on staff and that pressure
and then i forgot what else i was going
to follow up with but it sounds
i mean that's it's oh that is there a
breaking point
i mean you said it's not sustainable i
think we can see it's not sustainable
um is there a breaking point
i'll take that i'll take you off the
hook steve
so i mean um so here's
here's my best my best shot at this i
think every
everybody's um everybody's different
and it's the things that you can't see
you can quantify how many folks call in
sick you can quantify retirements you
can quantify
you know um absences but what you can't
is
what's going on in people's minds at
times you know and
uh so we've done a very i think a a
a good job i'm looking in the lower
right hand corner of my screen
and march 10th to me um is the day that
we really got
ramped up on on this whole culvert event
i believe the eoc opened up
um the 15th officially or the 16th but
it's been a year and it's been
um it's been a lot of work not only for
safety but for everybody
and i think the key is being able to
listen
um communicate let everybody understand
um we've had a lot of people it's okay
that to get sick
people get sick you've got a lot of
employees who've lost loved ones who've
uh you know haven't been able to see
family and
you know i think the only way we got
through it is we stuck together
and seven directors uh talking to the
employees
and uh and i think the fact that we're
here and we're operating and if you look
back representative murray
to all that's been done all that's been
accomplished
um i think uh i think we've managed as
best as we can but
um the key to the breaking point is
something that we're about to
unveil a as a wellness and resiliency
policy for the whole department
which is creating a culture that says
it's okay to raise your hand and say
i've had you know too much and it's okay
to say that you're bothered or impacted
and uh but i think that uh i think steve
what he's done pulling it together
running this budget
dealing with his own you know employees
he's got a big operation
you know just under 200 million dollar
budget to manage
without a number two and with many
vacancies shows
uh um why new hampshire's such a great
state
i mean and so i think the key is
and it's and we need your support i mean
you know what you said representative
keith i understand it i think if we all
stick together it's a process
we eventually get to where we need to be
and uh
you've done an amazing job i mean kudos
to you both and i think you know to
follow up on that with the wellness
and you know the human cost of it is
it's remarkable i mean it's been a tough
year and boyd's been hard on you all
you've borne the brunt of a lot of what
people have had to you know you're
almost so sort of the public face of a
disaster
well i get jen jenn hopper and uh
and fallon um at hsem and perry plummer
they worked all weekend i mean they have
they've been working seven days a week
you know they you look at the
vaccination and it's it's a lot
and uh i've been watching and it really
is impressive and i've been you know
i've worked with representative umberger
in division two for
you know since 2010 so i have faith in
division two
we eventually get to where we need to be
we will do our very very best for sure
um i was on a hop to 493 um
under the division of motor vehicles i
just what is financial responsibility as
it pertains to the department of motor
vehicles it's a couple
million dollars i just curious what is
what does that mean
so financial responsibility is that's
your driving records
and um anything if there's
violations that need to be paid or or
fines
that are processed that all happens
there your driving record gets updated
accordingly
if there's a suspension that occurs that
would get processed
if it's reinstated that's all processed
there
thank you i didn't know what that meant
i think i'm pretty near finished here if
other people want to pop in i'm just
going to check a few other things
other other questions please
i'm just i'm just flipping through my my
book
um okay
this is on page 507
uh it's um
it shows on a
number of positions 181
and is this where the shortage
of troopers or the unfunded position for
troopers would show up
so troopers are
funded throughout the budget they're not
all within one accounting unit
so there are some that are that are in
here
um the the
just to be clear we did we do have all
of our previously funded troopers so
troopers that were funded over the last
several biennium
are funded in this budget it's those
additional 23 that haven't been funded
for several biennium that are not and
and those are those are in various
accounting units some are here
summer um summer in 40 10 a few pages
yeah that's fine i just i was just
curious about that and these
um auxiliary police what do we
are those part-time hires or
how what is that yep those are those are
part-time troopers
um and so they are um
they really help the state police to
continue to provide all the services
they need some of them are helping out
with
um with with traffic control some are
helping out with investigations some are
helping out with um you know
peer-to-peer support activities
so they're really utilized in a broad
capacity
um to help provide services um that that
our full-time complement of troopers
just aren't aren't able to do
so representative ember in the past you
know several years with these vacancies
the auxiliaries have been critical um
handling background investigations not
they're not out there making arrests or
you know we've had some assigned to cold
case we've had some assigned to
you know uh uh the uh the niacc the
intelligence and analysis center
um the sex offender registry they've
gone in and
they've really kind of filled some gaps
we've had from having vacancies but i
look at the
you know we have a retired major that's
on the peer-to-peer unit
and you know and he has been extremely
busy
um you know helping and assisting and
managing um
the the health and well-being and the
training
that we're having all of the training
the cit training critical incident the
de-escalation training so
you know to to they're very important
okay i wasn't arguing that i just wanted
no i know
i just sometimes people say auxiliary
like what do they do right
and i just supposed to show the
importance of every single position
i mean but if one of those was to be
removed there'd be
you know duties that nobody could do
because they're doing
their own jobs you make me want to find
a way to volunteer
so
yeah uh president murray you could go in
and help with the fingerprinting
absolutely i know just sign me up
okay um i'm on page 509
and this is the um
enforcement
and um we're showing
the majority of this coming from the
general funds
so
yeah i'm just when i think of
enforcement i think about
traffic tickets but obviously that's not
what this is all about
so um so this is
there are two primary accounting units
for state police
one is 4003 um and and the other is this
one 4010
and we split them up because um this
accounting unit funds
state police activities associated with
troop stations
in keene in tamworth and in twin
mountain
and because of those locations the
patrol coverage area does not hit the
turnpikes any of the turnpikes
the 4003 account covers the other
troop stations which have turnpike
patrols
and therefore we can utilize turnpike
funds to support those operations
so that the reason why we've split them
this way is just for funding purposes
um and because of this is a perfect
example of what i was mentioning before
about how we're not really concerned
about the funding source
um this is the accounting unit that we
can shift
highway and general funds based on
availability as long as there's no
turnpike involved because turnpike would
not be appropriate to use for these
for these services okay so this
this is keene tamworth twin mountain
yes okay all right they probably have a
lot of dirt roads
they've got they've got a lot it's it's
the largest geographical
area in the city i know that that's out
here and so yeah there's a lot of
territory to cover
um it's just not uh we can't use the
turnpike money to do so
right well it makes sense i'm not
i was just trying to uh understand that
a little bit more uh
i think whoops what's this
oh yes this is on page
514.
it's the state police forensic lab
now is this the same forensic lab
or is this an additional forensic lab
or am i not reading this right
well this is the same lab um again
because of funding and
um all those wonderful things the the
the costs of the entire state police lab
are broken into three different
accounting units um you've got
and this is the primary accounting unit
with most of your
non-drug related activities so pattern
analysis
um tool analysis those those markings
your toxicology lab and the urine codis
those all fall under kind of what we
what the lab considers the toxicology
section
and that's dealing primarily with the
chemistry stuff and the drug
and the drug testing we could combine
everything together at some point but um
i have i have no problem with that as
long as i can
uh understand what it is yep so in this
particular area
um we we looked at the urine cotus
accounting unit at the beginning
there was one unfunded position here
there's 31
positions and seven of the unfundeds are
within this accounting unit
okay i'm i'm flipping
through here and i'm at the end
with no more questions all right are
there any
uh i see right sorry
you have a question yes it is basically
it's a
a general question um in terms of
uh there you've had to do a lot of um
reductions
across the board uh will there be any
costs that have to be downshifted to
municipalities
um with respect to what you've had to do
in your budget this year for this
biennium
no no i can't i can't think of any
um we we we've really
as i said before i mean this is and i'm
sure and i know that you understand
this isn't something you do with a um
this is something that that you have to
spend a lot of time thinking about and
looking at and
and we really took a risk-based approach
to make sure that
we could do as much as we could with
what was provided
and um i can't think of any areas
that would that would downshift any
costs
um to the locals there's no new fees in
here um
that the locals would be asked for you
know the lab services that we
talked about the lab a lot i mean it's
not the lab is funded by the state
um and the locals utilize that lab we're
not looking to change that model
you know we're not looking to push those
costs down um
but we're struggling to to fully fund
those areas
also so um i i don't see any any areas i
can't think of any areas where we've
done
anything like that thank you and steve i
just want to commend you again
you are a commissioner's dream
in terms of being able to do what you
have done
uh in a manner which you have done i i
guess it's thank god for excel but
it is a remarkable feat what you have
managed to do with this budget
as hard and difficult it is as it is
well thank you very much and and um it's
really it's a team effort over here
so i cannot take all the credit um and
uh we work really well together and it's
it's it's great working uh working on
this
with uh with this team and that's how we
get these things done
but thank you uh representative heath
what he doesn't tell you is he has a
dart board
in his office and so each
each morning he picks up a dart
and wherever it lands that's the answer
okay
i'm i'm just kidding steve as you know
uh mickey do we have any uh hb2
items that we need to uh look at today
uh we we visited them once with the
department last week we can go through
them again
i know we had some discussion on the
body warrant camera the dashboard camera
fund earlier
the department also has some transfer
authority that came up
as well as a discussion about adding
authority to fill unfunded positions so
if we want to get into house bill 2 and
revisit those sections again
with the department it's up to you um
does anybody feel a need to do that i
think i'm pretty clear
on on what what those issues are
and we're not going to decide them today
so i think the only other one was the
the radio
infrastructure equipment standards that
came up last time
to the department i don't want to have
any follow-up questions or need any
information on that
i think those are that's it right steve
for house bill 2.
yeah that's it for house bill 2. i i
think we're okay on those
so um
oh i'm sorry representative petrie of
your hand up
right uh this is kind of uh not
budget related but uh where did you go
to school steve
to know all this stuff
um i uh i have my i got my bachelor's at
riviera college in nashua
um and i got my um uh
my master's in accounting at southern
new hampshire university
um but the real place i went to school
was the lba
thank you uh we're i guess we're uh
co-alumnus from uh
his parents were school teachers he
won't share that with you he's got good
genes
yeah we we really have uh shared our lba
talent and uh around the uh around the
state
and i have told mickey that um
you know there's a ball and chain on his
uh
on his leg that he's not going anyplace
so okay um tomorrow
at uh 10 o'clock
we're going to have dot in
and on friday we're going to be talking
about
the university system
so and then uh next monday
the 16th no the 15th
whatever day it is we're going to have
the um
whatever it's called this those that
scholarship new scholarship
organization thing and um
that'll be on monday on
tuesday at one o'clock
we have the public hearing for the
budget
and for those of you that have
never gone to the public hearing on the
budget
i have no idea how long
this is going to last and
in talking to other committee
on normal times we have about
375 people that attend
and about 200 of them
want to talk however
since this will also be on zoom
and in talking to the other committees
they have had a significantly
higher participation
wanting to speak rate in numbers
than they have ever seen
so i
don't ask okay but we need to be sure
that we um that we listen to what
what they have to say and if i'm not
mistaken
we also have
a continued public hearing on
wednesday and i think that one's at four
so uh we will have our
regular two hour soda or so
session in the morning
and then um we'll we'll have
those in the afternoon uh friday we will
not be meeting
because i have a fiscal committee
meeting at 10
that's on the 19th and
and those are always
more fun than i can stand uh the last
time
that the ups driver brought me the stuff
he injured his back so i'm
just i'm just kidding but um
so that'll be that'll be next friday
morning
so busy week next week um
i'm also hoping that um
we can sort of uh finalize
next week the things that we all agree
on
okay i'm not sure exactly what those are
but we'll we'll go through them and
and the things that we agree on we will
uh get rid of so to speak uh we'll vote
on them
and the um the other things we'll
put off till later in the week or early
the following
week other than monday the following
week so
uh representative heath just a question
about
um i know in our last session we had a
number of bills that are coming our way
and um they're uh designated i think for
division two
do you have any idea when we're gonna
start looking at those yes
as a matter of fact i do mickey did we
decide that was on tuesday
i think so i think tuesday we were going
to do um
the the numbers escape me it's like
house bill 6 13 and 5 21 there's two of
them
i think you are going to allow for some
public input
public hearing for both and then we can
have a work session
uh following were you also planning on
doing a
budget work session wednesday yes
okay yeah wednesday and thursday
okay yeah okay
so that's next week um i have
i have a little bit of a hard time with
janet not reminding me
oh by the way you need to get your
schedule
in for the calendar so i
uh i try i try to remember to do that
but
that's one of those things that um you
know when you're when you're in the
state house it's easy for janet to run
in
and say oh by the way are you scheduling
anything for next week
so that's uh that's all
that i have is there anything that
anyone else has
i'll just add that we've heard from all
the agencies now if any of the members
have amendments that you'd like to talk
about or get drafted whether it's house
bill 1 or house bill 2 feel free to
reach out to me
because as we get really into it next
week
you know time's going to be of the
essence so if we can put some of those
thoughts down now so you're prepared to
have those discussions for the work
sessions in the next two weeks i think
that'd be good
yeah that's uh that's very true i know
uh
mickey has some uh i call them a little
housekeeping amendments that uh
that he's put together and uh you know
it's
no big deal at this point we do have
well they'll be we'll see what happens
okay
and um we'll also
see what happens on the uh general fund
money
because we've got some uh we've got some
decisions
to make and uh as we know
we don't none of us although looking at
mary's backyard
i think there must be a money tree
hiding in there someplace
have we heard from ways and means about
you know specifically
what we're going to be dealing with uh
yeah they're not giving us any more
money
other than what we all voted on whenever
that was
but that's it so
um we're still
you know we're still maneuvering
through this and we we as a group need
to come to a decision
about some things so
but that'll be next week and
early the following week uh yes
representative heath
thank you um along with that have you
been given an amount
for our division that we have to
reduce no thank you
thank you that doesn't mean no
reductions it just means
no one has given me a target
hey if nothing else representative lynn
i missed your hand
thank you i i have a question just as
sort of the newcomer on the block
um i want to i want to just ask if if uh
if if if this division sort of follows
what
what had been my experience from
division one when i was at the court
um that if that let's assume that we
have to make that we
you know we conclude that we have to
make some cuts then i'll just use safety
as an example because they're here
um from from what they've proposed
and assuming that it's not that
you know let's assume that we
as a member of division two were not
were not
we didn't have a particular acts to
grind that we thought you know the cut
should come from here or the cut should
come from there but we just kind of felt
uh that that there needed to be a there
needed to be a reduction
it was my experience in dealing with
division one when i was on the court
that they would normally
come back to us and say look we're going
to cut you by this much
but you know you kind of choose
where it's going to come from and as
long and again as long as it wasn't
something that the
division one thought you know this is
outrageous um
we would uh division one generally would
would defer to our choice and is it is
that
do we sort of follow the same general
idea here
well the the difference between division
one and three and division two
is that we have the education trust fund
the highway fund and fish and game fund
which is obviously all
outside of the um
the general fund and so
we do have general funded things
in each of those divisions
for each of those departments but
compared to
division one or to division three
it's pretty minuscule and so
it's we have to balance all of that out
and um it you know
for example um you know for fish and
game
i'll use that one because it's easy to
cut the hundred thousand dollars that
we've given them
in jennifer that's out there in general
funds
um that's a requirement you know
for the uh wildlife match
or i think it's wildlife it's something
maybe it's wild flowers
but you know that's a match so we can't
we can't eliminate that
100 000 match and many of the
items that go on in education
in safety are also
required matches in order for us to
obtain federal funds and
that's just not true necessarily
obviously in health and human services
it is true to some degree
but in division one um
i'm not sure that that they have a lot
of
what i would call federal match programs
sure no i understand thank you thank you
for the clarification
okay we'll see you tomorrow morning
take care bye-bye thank you